you dropped the uh 5l
um is this a warm-up for an album
oh yeah they're gonna have to deal with
me a lot next year yeah I'll let you
know now yeah how much music are you
sitting on
unlimited I record every day every day
no I can't even put a number on the
amount of songs I got so for you it's
like
it's almost like you're recording
because you love to do it yeah I like
recording I like talking [ __ ] I like
standing on my way if you record every
day the chances of everything coming out
are probably slim right
so it's like oh and I was like it ain't
slim I just know what people like to
hear I'm saying like is it like almost
like practice too like you know what I
might record today I ain't even feeling
it today but I'm gonna get in and just
see what happens just to kind of get my
shots up one thing I don't do I enforce
it I don't force I Don't Force It yeah
it's nothing like
like I just let it happen
what is uh what's your writing process
you punch in are you writing stuff down
or I put I punch in yeah you're not
punching like
I can't I can't I can't write like I can
write hold on let me say that before
they take this [ __ ] right I can count I
can spill all this [ __ ] hold up but yeah
like like with songs like I look at it
like art I can't just
write it down on the paper because I'm a
I'ma say it a certain way other than me
just going in there and freestyle off
the top of my head punching in it's like
I got a blank sheet of paper I got a
blank canvas I'm just gonna you know
what I'm saying I'm gonna just go for
what I know rather than having a a book
with pictures I already made you know
what I'm saying plus the Beats got to
speak to you right it's like what you
sure if you play the beat the beat is
like a feature that's how I look at it
hey your beat selection has been it's
always been crazy yeah yeah your ear for
Beats is special it's one of the best in
the game what do you attribute that to
you proud of my grandma
um my grandmother yeah your beat yo
you're you're you got it here for beat
thing I feel like you can a r some like
some other people [ __ ] you might help
them out no for sure I know I can yeah
because I feel like we always hear
somebody like damn like like yourself
Rick Ross has also got a crazy ear for
Beats
um
but yeah salute to you for right because
I mean that's one thing your production
ain't never [ __ ] slacking I don't
know do you like have like a crew that
you're always [ __ ] with in terms of
the beats are you always looking for new
beats like
I ain't gonna lie you know it's like I'm
just too much care about the names like
you got this [ __ ] and it's right here in
front of me like
I'm gonna off on the road with it like
one thing with me like
I don't like I don't like people to send
me beats um
I'm more of a Hands-On person like I'd
rather you be in the studio with me you
ain't got to make the beat right there
but I'd rather you just
go through your [ __ ] right there with me
like you know what I'm saying and then
if you like something they can pull up
the the stems and take [ __ ] out of it I
like this Loop but I don't like the
drums I don't did that a lot with
probably half of my songs I put out I
[ __ ] with the beats